nowadays it's getting rarer and rarer
that a new anime becomes a so-called
Hidden Gem everything's being watched
everything's being reviewed even with a
huge amount of anime getting released
all the amazing shows Bubble Up in
history remembers here are the actual
good shows and here are the ones that
didn't quite meet the hype but this
season we're living in some Bizarro
world where freaking everything is good
so you've got several shows I'm
absolutely gobsmacked more people aren't
watching but it's simply because people
are watching other great shows that
simply had more initial hype behind them
but I mean I've been doing anime YouTube
for like over 10 years now and I feel
like some of these shows just need a
little bit more of a push to get the
recognition they deserve because it's
such an easy sell like for example I can
say are you watching VV and you're like
no and then I say why not it's like a
cross between Violet evergarden the
Terminator and near automata written by
the same guy did re-zero but then you're
like okay but so then I show you this
foreign
[Music]
but sometimes you come across a show
that's harder to sell something you
can't just show a cool scene or
summarize in one clickbaity tagline but
you know that if you just convince
someone to give it a chance they're
gonna think it [ __ ] slaps and that's
basically odd taxi odd taxi is one of
those Series where you watch one episode
and you're like hey this seems pretty
cool I might give this a watch but let
me see what else is on offer first
oh
hey what was this about again because
that's exactly what happened to me but
thankfully being a good old Nihon
resident the series was inescapable if
you ever rode a taxi in the last six
months in Tokyo cause hey guys it's a
series called odd taxi about a taxi
driver in Tokyo so let's put it on the
back of every taxi in Tokyo ever genius
actually you know what that was [ __ ]
genius because it reminded me to watch
it and if I didn't I would have missed
one of the most engrossing anime on
offer this year paired with some of the
best writing I've seen in a while
welcome to the underbelly of Tokyo the
backdrop for a class of colorful
characters that seemingly have nothing
to do with each other an enthusiastic
college student looking for any way to
get viral or a desperate Bachelor who
would do anything to get a date a tired
on Earth with the secret of her own a
sleazy gangster looking to please his
boss there's an idol group and the
biggest fan a stand-up comedy duo
corrupt cop and somewhere in the middle
of all this there's a mysterious girl
who's just gone missing somewhere in the
city but what's all this got to do with
anything what initially seems like a
group of unrelated characters on their
own Journey slowly starts to
interconnect as the mystery is unraveled
their paths start to intertwine with
each other and right at the center of
all this there's one single Taxi Driver
who's run out of [ __ ] to give it can be
hard to tell what the hook of this show
is meant to be or what the show is even
about at the beginning because you are
introduced to so many different things
that seemingly have nothing to do with
each other but it's one of those shows
where if you have the patience to stick
around you'll be rewarded as the puzzle
pieces start fitting together and the
dot starts getting connected nothing is
there for show everything has a purpose
for those who pay attention you might
even be able to make sense of it all
before it's fully revealed this is a
mature mystery thriller that's often
been compared to Tarantino movies and
honestly I absolutely agree not just
with the format of presenting a grand
narrative with a bunch of interconnected
characters but just the feel of the
whole thing there's just something about
the dialogue in Tarantino movies that is
so addicting you hear these characters
talk and it just doesn't sound like your
typical movie dialogue it feels so
natural yet it's not exactly realistic
either you know as much as I would like
to think I can have tarantino-esque
dialogue with the boys on the Saturday
night at the pub it's almost as if you
get a snapshot of the optimized version
of naturally occurring dialogue you
recognize the conversations but there's
a certain Rhythm to it people are on the
top of their game everyone says exactly
the right thing at the perfect time to
say it it's like conversational poetry
and odd taxi captures this energy
perfectly it's witty it's Snappy it's
human conversation in Peak form and
sometimes it'll throw a curveball at you
like you could have two characters
having this deep intimate conversation
this guy is telling this girl to stay
away from him it's unsafe he has
dangerous people after him he's involved
in something bigger than himself and for
her own good she shouldn't be involved
with him and in response to that this
happens
foreign
[Music]
what everything about the show exudes
this energy of an indie anime I mean
it's not it's by Pony Cannon but it just
somehow feels so vastly different from
your usual otaku bait seasonal anime
Pulp Fiction No Country for Old Men Taxi
Driver before thinking of other anime
this is comparable to these are the
things that come to mind when I think of
what our taxi is like so what is it
about the writing that makes this show
stand out you may have heard the term
chekhov's gun the concept where no
element in the story that is presented
to the viewer should be unnecessary in
the words of Anton Chekhov himself if
you say in the first chapter there's a
rifle hanging on the wall in the second
or third chapter it's absolutely must go
off if it's not going to be fired it
shouldn't be hanging there
I [ __ ] knew it of course this doesn't
always have to refer to a literal gun
but any object or element that is
introduced should lead to an eventual
payoff I'm sure you've all watched or
read a story where a big plot element
was set up and introduced that didn't
actually lead anywhere or mean anything
at the end and you're just left there
thinking so wait what the [ __ ] was the
point of brown being able to possess
animals again the reason I bring this up
is because unfortunately odd taxi
doesn't have a chekhov's gun that's
right he has a [ __ ] check off Arsenal
this year probably breaks the check off
Geneva Convention is getting tried at
the check off un for check off war
crimes hold on a second I've just
finished watching our taxi and I'm on my
way back my check off Apache helicopter
it's a rare sight when you see a script
where seemingly every single little bit
of detail has a purpose as a writer it
can be easy to forget about small
aspects or just look over certain
elements but odd taxi manages to juggle
so many characters so many different
story lines intertwining them into this
chaotic mess that somehow becomes
coherent when the end is in sight the
script is so tight it can fix your leaks
better than Flex Seal one thing leads to
another which affects something else
which connects everything together tick
after talk after tick after talk the ebb
and flow of the series is like watching
a ruby Goldberg machine in motion every
episode you're given a new puzzle piece
no scene unnecessary no single piece of
dialogue wasted but for every new
breadcrumb you are given the whole
picture slowly but surely becomes more
visible plot lines intertwine characters
crash into each other tension builds up
until eventually everything is revealed
it's absolutely incredible how much care
and attention has gone into the writing
here there could be a scene where
characters could be having this
seemingly random conversation about the
matter of Tinder profiles and you don't
realize until a few episodes later that
a piece of information was exchanged
that gave a clue to what was really
going on or a single shot somehow four
shadowed Wars about to come it's like
the writer has a chronic fear of loose
ends because no stone is left unturned
or detail left unchecked and here I am
watching this being like [ __ ] I can't
even keep track of where I put my phone
like five minutes ago and
[ __ ]
all right this this isn't actually part
of the script but I literally can't find
my phone right now but in between the
grander plot you have these really
personal grounded stories surrounding
the various casts that can hit a little
bit too uncomfortably close to home
sometimes a lot of these characters just
seems like dudes you've known struggling
with some kind of insecurity and because
of that you want to root for them even
through their worst decisions there's a
dude who's just obsessed with trying to
get popular online and um I don't know
can't really relate to that there's this
dude who's taking out loans to make it
seem like he's as rich as he said he was
in his Tinder profile and I'm like come
on man can't you just be like a normal
sane person and subscribe to and only
fans like everyone else but for me the
standout one is the one depicted in
episode four cause this may be the
single best Standalone episode of this
spring anime season at first you're like
what kind of episode is this we're
focusing on a character we've never seen
before with no previous connection to
the plot and we've gone from a missing
person's Mystery Case to a guy playing
gacha games what the hell is going on
but as this guy tells his story you
start to get absorbed from a simple boy
who just wants to be accepted by his
friends who just wants to feel like one
of the cool kids for once two and overly
competitive Obsession of collecting
erasers one mistake leads to another one
Domino follows another Domino follows
another Domino follows another every
part of his life feels like he was
fueled by the mistakes of his previous
actions you see the Journey of a
perfectly sane man spiraled down into
the darkest depths of GATRA addiction
because well this is his fate this is is
what his life had led to this is what he
was meant to do and as this all plays
out his place in the story starts to
make sense the dots start connecting and
when everything's said and done you have
a man who's completely snapped because
he couldn't get some bird in a gacha
game I mean wow what a psycho right
couldn't be me imagine losing your mind
over a [ __ ] dodo like what I mean
come on it doesn't even have a swimsuit
edition it's rare to find storytelling
as engrossing as this and for God's
sakes it's about a guy playing a [ __ ]
gacha game but this episode perfectly
captures what makes this such a standout
show I feel like there's something else
big I forgot to mention about this show
oh yeah they're animals
did you notice look I know what you
first thought was when you saw these
designs because it was my first thought
as well oh hey another show to add to
anime's furry phase we're apparently
going through now you know it was cool
when B stars came out but if I have to
sell another show with the tagline it's
like zootopia but I might just have to
put on a fursuit myself and [ __ ] awoo
myself to death but honestly I don't
think it's actually anything like that
because the fact that their animals
plays such a small part of the show in
fact it hardly plays any part of the
show although these series Blends human
behavior with animal characteristics but
here their animal size are hardly ever
referred to at all to the point where a
lot of people have thought that this was
just a live action drama in Disguise so
why the [ __ ] can't we just see that
version I want to get married I want to
have babies before I'm like 26 do you
have health insurance
actually you know what let's just keep
it out of me all taxi is an absolute
master class in writing that I know a
lot of people have looked over and
without having just come recently to an
end it's been a while since I've seen a
series this complete with a mystery
series as plot heavy as this anime's had
a bad repressly of kind of dropping the
ball when it came to the ending or just
leaving us with something unsatisfactory
with everything it built up odd taxi
however didn't just stick its Landing it
[ __ ] did a triple double backflip
twist with one hand type on his back
landed on two feet and casually got gold
in the Olympics in the process it's been
so long since I've seen an anime with a
story that was just the full package
from start to finish miniseries have
struggled and failed trying to juggle
less than what's going on here but by
the final episode the series not only
managed to weave everything into one
coherent narrative made sure every
Chekhov gun was fired in spectacular
fashioned tied up all its Loose Ends but
it also somehow did it all seamlessly it
doesn't have the flashy visuals or the
big names behind it or the pre-existing
fan base to Hype it up but what it does
have is just pure engrossing
storytelling I know it's a busy season I
know there are much more high profile
titles out there I know these animal
character designs aren't the most
appealing things in the world but I do
sincerely hope that more people check
this out this had an uphill battle from
the start to get noticed and I think a
series like this was always going to be
classified as that underwatched
underappreciated Hidden Gem
but you know what maybe we can change
that
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video let
me just Sorry
God damn this is a good opening thank
you very much to levada Pony Star
dysfunctional degenerate Alpha Sigma
Jeff and everyone else my Patron for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible look guys I
know June was a bit of a quiet month for
me but I was actually really busy but I
was actually really busy but I actually
had a really really busy schedule off
this channel doing stuff for other
channels so that's why you didn't get
many videos that month but also I've
been working on some super big videos as
well which you can expect this month so
this is going to be a much busier month
than last month so we're starting this
month with an odd taxi video I really
hope you enjoyed it because more [ __ ]
people need to watch it I know this
isn't going to be the most viewed video
on my channel but my gods I hope those
of you who did actually watch this video
you end up giving it a shot because it
really does deserve it but yeah you can
expect a much more regular upload
schedule this month than Beyond so yeah
I'll just leave that up for today
because I have no further updates so
everyone I hope you have a wonderful day
I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time